pour en savoir plus sur la
responsabilité de maurice papon dans la
manifestation d'algériens qui s'était
terminée dans le sang à paris le 17
octobre 1961
catherine trautmann ministre de la
culture a donc décidé hier l'ouverture
des archives sur cet événement une levée
du secret qui soulève déjà une polémique
au sein des syndicats de police valérie
fournier au lendemain du 17 octobre 61
toutes ces images sur la répression de
la manifestation des algériens ont été
sélectionnés et épuré censure d'état
même silence autour de toute trace
écrite secret là encore que le ministre
de la culture vient de décider de lever
la loi m'autorise à lever
exceptionnellement le secret des
archives pour les périodes qui sont en
fait bloqué pour des raisons de
protection
je dirais des individus pas si simple
les archives sont disséminés entre
plusieurs lieux plusieurs institutions
l'institut médico légal
le ministère de la défense sur le rôle
joué par la gendarmerie et la préfecture
de police
le ministre de l'intérieur jean pierre
chevènement aurait lui aussi donné son
accord mais les syndicats de police
s'affiche aujourd'hui très divisée le
syndicat alliance marqué à droite
s'insurge contre cette levée du secret
pourquoi pas après tout ne pas vider
l'abcès une bonne fois pour toute et
puis on limite on en parle plus on aura
quand même en mémoire
mais c'est vrai qu'il ya eu je peux vous
assurer sa des répercussions morales sur
les chaussées jeune fonctionnaire et le
vivent mal
quant aux policiers en tenue de la
centrale unitaire majoritaire en région
parisienne ils souscrivent pleinement à
l'initiative de madame trautmann et
réclame la mise en place d'une
commission d' enquête